so thank you all very much for coming to
these this yci workshop yelled climate
and energy institute workshop and I'd
like to thank the yell climate and
energy institute for funding it the
director is right there mark Pagani you
can thank him personally so the YC I
likes to fund these sort of
interdisciplinary workshops and so there
are lots of these going on on and off my
name is Mary Louise Timmermans for
people who don't know me and I'm an
assistant professor in the geology and
geophysics department I'd like to thank
all of our speakers for coming long
distances we've gathered together quite
a crowd of interdisciplinary speakers
with a broad range of expertise and a
broad range of topics and the general
theme for today is a series of talks
that looks at high latitude long-term
climate parameters environmental
parameters spanning time scales from
thousands of years to the present day
and talks also on the human history and
archaeological record in the high
latitude and Arctic and so the
motivation for this workshop is the
understanding that we can learn a lot
more about both human history and
climate through the integration of
environmental knowledge with studies of
the archaeological record and so that's
that's the main motivation for this
workshop and tomorrow we'll really just
be a discussion a discussion session
among a very broad with with a broad
range of expertise in the room and it
will be really a conversation between
all of these these different disciplines
to try to pin down what are some of the
big
issues and how can we make advances
through these interdisciplinary
collaborations so that's all I'm going
to say let's have lots of questions and
interaction throughout the day lots of
discussion as much as possible and I'm
going to kick off with our first speaker
so I'll introduce Jennifer Francis who's
our first speaker by the way we've had a
slight change in the schedule
unfortunately um Astrid Ogilvy was going
to come and she is a speaker at
eleven-forty-five and she couldn't make
it so um but in her place we have a very
special speaker ray Bradley from UMass
Amherst is going to give us a talk and
the title of his talk is Holocene Arctic
climate variability past present and
future okay so that's a slight change so
let's start with Jennifer Francis
Jennifer Francis is a research professor
at the rutgers institute of marine and
coastal sciences and studies Arctic
climate change and Arctic global climate
linkages she co-founded and co-directed
the Rutgers climate and environmental
change initiative and most recently
jennifer is very well known for her work
understanding the relationship between
Arctic warming and our weather patterns
here in the mid latitudes and today
she's going to tell us about rapid
Arctic warming and changing weather
patterns in mid-latitudes is there a
connection thanks number good morning
everybody and thank you for inviting me
to be here Mary Louise it's really fun
to be in this group and i love these
interdisciplinary groups because i
always learn so much about a lot of
different topics that i don't usually
think about very much so hopefully what
i'm going to talk about is something
that you're not used to thinking about
either and i realized that there are
mostly not atmospheric science people in
the room so i will try to keep this at a
relatively easy to understand level but
if you have any questions along the way
please yell or throw something or
whatever you need to do to get my
attention
so i hearing you describe this workshop
i realize that i'm definitely at one end
of the temporal spectrum of this
discussion that we're having here my
archaeology goes back about 30 years so
definitely on the short end of things
but i would like to tell you a little
bit about this very recent work that
I've been doing and that now a lot of
other people are focusing on as well and
that is the fact that we know the Arctic
is warming very rapidly two or three
times faster than the rest of anywhere
else on the planet and we think that
there's a direct connection to mid
latitude weather patterns in particular
certain types of extreme weather
patterns so I've been doing this work
together with my colleague Steve avarice
at the University of Wisconsin so let's
start with a painful memory on a
beautiful day like this this memory
starting to fade but this was actually
Chicago for most of this winter and
there I'm still hearing whining from a
lot of my friends and colleagues in the
middle of the country and we were spared
somewhat on in the east coast here but
this is what they faced all winter long
this was the attack of the polar vortex
which was all over the news and a friend
of mine sent me this cartoon which I
think summarizes the sentiment of people
in the middle of the country pretty darn
well this was in The New Yorker but if
we look back only two years so here we
are back in the winter of 2012 we see a
very different picture instead of seeing
very cold temperatures over the eastern
two-thirds of the country we saw
extremely warm temperatures and during
this March of 2012 we broke thousands of
high temperature records not cold so
keep that in mind we're going to come
back to that and just to remind you of
some of the other extreme events that
have happened around the northern
hemisphere in the last couple years over
the last two or three winters we've had
nor'easter after nor'easter in New
England this was in scituate
Massachusetts near where I live of
course last winter the UK was bombarded
with storm after storm they bro
they're all time rain record or
precipitation record going back two
hundred and fifty years Alaska a couple
years ago had unprecedented flooding in
southeast Alaska and even Greenland has
been experiencing flooding like they've
never seen and then there's the cold
Europe has had some very cold winters as
had much of Asia especially Western
Eurasia and that cold has extended all
the way down to the Black Sea to the
north coast of the Mediterranean and
some of the inhabitants of Eastern
Europe have been very upset by this
change in the weather so they're just
not happy and in northern Japan where
they're used to getting a lot of snow
they have been seeing record amounts of
snow you can't even imagine the snow
plow that keeps that road clear and then
again there's been the heat waves all
across northern hemisphere in the
summers but this picture looks like it's
typical heat wave but in fact this was
in march in burlington vermont in 2012
all across the country especially in the
west and southwest they've been dealing
with heat waves and droughts texas a lot
of the marinas there are no longer
marinas eurasia as well has been dealing
with heat waves and droughts and of
course we know California's in a very
situation right now so what do these
particular extreme events have in common
they're all related to weather patterns
that are basically been stuck or very
persistent weather patterns so when I
talk about extreme weather events i'm
not talking about tornadoes or
hurricanes or hail but i'm talking about
extreme events that are related to
weather patterns that are very
slow-moving and persistent so people are
starting to notice that weather is
changing and they're starting to ask
what the heck's going on in particular
whether there's a connection to climate
change and it hasn't been very long that
scientists people studying this problem
have been
willing to step up and say that yes
there is a connection there have been
enough new studies lately making some
direct links between climate change and
extreme weather events that I think we
can now say that there are some direct
links not all extreme events of course
but certain types so I like to step back
and remind everybody of the pickle that
we've gotten ourselves in you've all
seen a graph like this many times or
most of you have I'm sure looking back
in time four hundred and thirty thousand
years and we see that temperature in red
here has oscillated back and forth over
the millennia we know what causes that
it's changes in the Earth's orbit
changes in the tilt of the earth and we
know that the co2 concentration in the
atmosphere changes alongside the
temperature changes until you get up to
recent times and we see that carbon
dioxide has spiked very very rapidly and
we know that the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere now is higher than it's been
in at least 800,000 years but we also
noticed that the temperature has not yet
caught up with this very high level of
carbon dioxide that's in the atmosphere
now and we know why that is too because
the oceans are like a big flywheel in
the climate system it takes a lot of
energy to warm them up and it takes time
for them to equilibrate with the amount
of carbon dioxide we have in the
atmosphere but we also know that the
last time we had this much carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere sea levels
were much higher the earth was several
degrees warmer and this is the path that
were headed on right now and we also
know that the earth is starting to catch
up in terms of its global average
temperature so going back only a
thousand years now we see that
temperatures fluctuated somewhat around
an average with a general cooling trend
overall but more recently we've seen the
temperatures start to spike on the
global average and many of the love the
warmest years we recorded have been only
in the last couple of decades we also
know this warming that's happening is
not uniform across the earth so as we
look at temperature anomalies for the
last decade or so we see the red colors
are concentrated up in the far north the
Arctic is warming much faster than
everywhere else and interestingly this
warming that's been happening has been
very steady and in fact the past this
past March was the three hundred and
forty ninth month in a row that was
above average so if you're younger than
29 years old you have never experienced
a month that was cooler than average not
only is the atmosphere getting warmer
it's also taking up more moisture and we
can see that this plot going back to the
1970s or so shows a definite increase in
the amount of water vapor in the
atmosphere and that increase is
completely consistent with the amount of
warming that's happened in the
atmosphere as well about a seven percent
increase in water vapor with a one
degree warming and we know this is
important because that water vapor does
a couple of things it not only provides
more moisture for any storm that forms
now so we see heavier precipitation
events as a result but it also provides
a lot of energy for any storms that form
now but as we look to the future using
climate models we know that the changes
in precipitation patterns are also not
going to happen evenly around the globe
so this is a projection for the end of
the century for December January
February on the left and summer months
Northern Hemisphere summer on the right
and you don't need to see the detail but
it shows basically that the dry areas on
the planet will become even drier and
the moist areas especially in high
latitudes will become even wetter at
least that's what the models say so
taking the temperature changes and the
moisture changes into account one of the
analogies that you can use is that
mother nature is now playing with a
different deck of cards so if you wanted
to play poker with mother nature she's
now got a couple of extra aces and kings
and her deck so you've got a better
chance of getting a good hand if you're
playing poker then you used to but you
don't you're not necessarily going to
have a good hand
so moving up to the Arctic now which is
where I've been focusing most of my
attention over my career I'm sure you
all know that the sea ice in the Arctic
is now has changed dramatically so if we
look back only 30 years so this is the
end of summer in 1980 when that sea ice
which is the pink stuff floating there
on the Arctic Ocean is at its minimum
extent this is what it looked like back
then so it pretty much filled up the
whole Arctic Ocean but if we fast
forward now to 2012 we see that the
amount of sea ice in the Arctic has now
decreased by half in only 30 years we've
lost half of the aerial coverage of sea
ice and if you take into account the
thickness changes of that sea ice what
we find is that seventy-five percent of
the volume of sea ice has been lost just
in the last 30 years and what's left you
can kind of see from the color
differences compared to the 1980 the sea
ice that's there now is thinner it's
broken it's fragile so any anomalies
that come along in the winds or the
ocean currents have a much bigger impact
now than they would have 30 years ago
but people ask well how unusual is this
is this just a short-term blip and
what's happening in the Arctic well we
can actually look back about 1500 years
using sediment cores and estimate how
much ice there was in the summertime in
the Arctic Ocean and that's what's being
shown here so what you see going back
about 1500 years yet they're illegals
around from year to year but until you
get to present here which is this blue
dotted line and you can see that now
we're in completely uncharted territory
compared to the last fifteen hundred
years but this graph doesn't even have
2012 on it and if you want to put 2012
on there you really have to redraw the
graph
I don't know a lot of detail about it
but my understanding is that the
sediments at the bottom of the Arctic
Ocean contain dead organisms and those
organisms differ depending on whether
there was ice floating on the surface or
not in the summer so you can reconstruct
the area of the ice based on the type of
organisms that were there in the in the
muck cool so not only was 2012 a tough
year for the sea ice but it was also a
tough year for other aspects of the
Arctic for one thing we know that the
amount of snow on high latitude land
areas has been decreasing dramatically
so this is going back to the late 1960s
showing the amount of snow during June
but may and july months look exactly the
same and starting around the mid 90s or
so we've had this very dramatic decline
in the amount of snow on high latitude
land areas the reason that's important
is because if we're losing that snow
much earlier in the spring that exposes
the soil underneath to the strong spring
sunshine that dries out the soil earlier
warms up the land earlier and that gives
a jump start to the summer season so we
think this is contributing to the
increasing tendencies for heat waves and
droughts on the northern hemisphere
continents and we've done some work on
that that demonstrates this is happening
we can also look at Greenland over the
last couple of decades and see what's
been happening there if we go back to
nineteen ninety two the orange areas
here on the surface of Greenland show
you what parts of the sort of the snow
on top of Greenland underwent some
amount of melting during that summer so
there you have 1992 only a decade later
you see that that area has increased
dramatically 2005 only three years after
that it expanded more and in 2012
ninety-seven percent of the surface of
Greenland underwent some melt that was
the year that that flood happened that I
showed you in the beginning the changes
are just amazing so why do we
about the loss of ice and snow in the
Arctic well we know that ice is very
bright it's very white here I'm showing
again the 2012 ice cover here in white
and this pink line shows the average for
the last few decades as the Sun hits
that very white ice most of the solar
energy gets reflected right back to
outer space it never enters the climate
system at all but because we have so
much less ice now much more of that
energy from the Sun is going into the
Arctic Ocean it's warming the Arctic
Ocean accumulating there all summer long
so and that's part of the reason why the
Arctic is warming so fast this is one of
the main factors and why do we care
about that well we're going to learn a
little meteorology here for some of you
who don't aren't meteorologists let's
think about a layer of atmosphere a
layer of air extending from here in New
Haven Connecticut all the way to the
Arctic and we know that warm air takes
up more room than cold air does warm air
expands so this layer of air is thicker
here in the vertical than it would be in
the Arctic so this layer of air forms a
hill if you will so if you were sitting
on top of this layer here in New Haven
you it would be like you were looking
down hill as you were looking towards
the north so the air on top of this
layer wants to flow down that hill just
like water wanting to flow down the hill
of a mountain it starts flowing which
creates a wind and because the earth is
spinning that wind gets turned to the
right and that becomes what we call the
jet stream the jet stream is this high a
ribbon of fast-moving air high over our
heads now because the Arctic is warming
so much faster than it is here in New
Haven the thickness of that atmospheric
layer is increasing more in the Arctic
than it is here so the effect is that
that heel is actually becoming less deep
so there's less force driving that wind
that becomes the jet stream so we'd
expect to see the west to east winds of
the jet stream decrease as a read
dolt of Arctic amplification we call it
which is the extra warming that's
happening in the Arctic so we can
actually measure the speed of those
winds and that's what's being shown here
going back to the late 1970s so the
solid black line there is the speed of
the wind about half way up through the
atmosphere and how it's changed over
since the late 1970s there's been about
a ten percent decline on average around
the northern hemisphere during the fall
and I show the fall mostly because
that's when the effect of the sea ice
loss is the largest and this extra
warming and the at in the atmosphere in
the Arctic is the largest and you can
see also plotted on there is what's been
happening with the sea ice extent at the
same time so as the sea ice has really
started to decline so has the speed of
the wind and we know that when those
upper level winds become weaker the jet
stream tends to take a wavier path as it
travels around the northern hemisphere
so you can remember this with this
little tongue twister weaker westerly
wind is weightier so we can the reason
this is important is because if those
waves are in fact becoming wavier if
they're becoming larger we know that
those waves tend to move more slowly
from west to east and that's what's
being shown in these animations here so
up in the top panel here these waves
have a smaller amplitude they tend to
shift from west to east fast but as the
waves get larger which is shown down in
the bottom here they tend to slow down
and move more slowly from west to east
so why should you care about that well
let's take a look at what the jet stream
really does so here's a schematic of the
jet stream that orange line that goes
across the northern hemisphere there the
first thing to notice is that it
separates the cold air to the north from
the warm air to the south so depending
on whether the jet stream is north or
south of you determines whether you're
in cold air or warm air but also even
more important are these waves that I
was talking about and depending on where
you are
to one of these waves it those waves
determine the weather that is happening
where you are so if you're in this part
of the wave where the winds are coming
from the southwest high over your head
you're in a very stormy pattern and if
you're in this part of the way where the
winds are basically from the northwest
you're in a very dry settled pattern
with high pressure so this means that if
these waves are moving more slowly from
west to east as they get larger so these
weather conditions that those waves
create is hanging around longer in your
location this is the idea so now let's
take a look at the real jet stream and
you'll see that it doesn't look quite
like this nice simple orange line so
here we are looking down on the Arctic
and these are real winds that have been
mapped by NASA's science visualization
studio the red colors here are showing
you where the winds are the strongest
indicating where the jet stream is and
as I put this in motion and we rotate
down over North America what you're
going to see is that first of all the
atmosphere is a terribly messy place
there are waves of all kinds and sizes
there are swirls happening all over the
place and these waves move sometimes
very quickly sometimes very slowly so
I'm going to show this one more time
because i want to point out some
conditions when you'll see that when the
waves are smaller they move quickly as i
said across across the northern
hemisphere and when they're large they
slow down so here's a case when the
waves are quite small and when i put it
in motion again you'll see that they
move quite quickly across the continent
and then there are times when the waves
get much larger like this and you'll see
that they tend to get pretty much stuck
in place and that means the weather that
they're creating is also being very
persistent in those locations where
those waves aren't moving and it
sometimes they're even create Eddie's
like you saw in the end there and that
becomes very persistent
okay so how do you measure something
like this you saw how messy the
atmosphere is how can we measure what's
happening with these waves in the jet
stream well one of the ways we do it is
we map that layer of atmosphere that I
showed you that was thicker here than it
was in the Arctic and we can treat it
just like a topographic map that you'd
use for hiking so here's a topographic
map of that layer of the atmosphere the
red colors are where the atmosphere is
thicker or the land would be higher and
the purple colors show where there'd be
a valley or the colder air and these
black lines indicate where the height of
that layer is the same so it's just like
on a topographic map for hiking if you
followed one of those lines you can stay
at a constant elevation and that's
what's being shown here as well so these
lines then we can use to track the shape
and size of these waves in the upper
level flow of the atmosphere you can see
those waves as you there's a big way big
northward swing in the jet stream the
jet stream is identified by where these
waves where these lines are very close
together that's where the wind speeds
are very strong and you can see that
there are places where there are big
dips in the jet stream so these big
north and south swings so we can look at
these maps like this every single day
and track the sizes of these waves so
here's a sort of zooming in on the on
the you're on the North Atlantic here
the same topographic map of the
atmosphere and what we see is one of
these big waves in the upper level flow
and in fact it's formed what we call a
blocking high and that's when we get one
of these Eddie's breaking off and
forming a circulation pattern in the
upper atmosphere and these are called
blocking because when they form they
tend to block the atmosphere in place
and lock it in place and the weather
patterns associated with that wave don't
change these create very very persistent
weather patterns there's been a lot of
focus on these blocking highs that over
the years because they are have such a
big impact on weather patterns in a
particular extreme weather
but what we've been noticing as we look
at particular extreme events is that
many of these events are not associated
with blocking highs per se but instead
are just very amplified or very large
waves in the upper level flow like this
case in March of 2012 which was a bit
the big heat wave in the eastern half of
our country this was a big flooding
event in Spain where they had their
Spain right there where they had the
worst flooding they've had ever in
September again just a big wave no
blocking this is the situation when
Japan had that very heavy snowfall
there's Japan right there another case
this is this past winter actually when
we were attacked by the polar vortex so
we have shifted our focus in our in our
work from these blocking events to just
extreme wave events and the way we're
measuring that is going back to our
topographic maps and picking a
particular constant elevation contour
that tracks the shape of these waves in
the upper level flow so this is showing
you an example of one of these and we
look for cases when the farthest
northern latitude and the farthest
southern latitude of this contour is
large it's a very simple technique but
with a different focus and when we do
that and we track these extreme waves
over time what we find is that they are
in fact increasing in frequency and
that's what's being shown here in the
green line this is very new work that
hasn't been published yet this is for
the whole northern hemisphere during
fall and the Green Line is showing you
the frequency of these extreme extreme
waviness events if you will and also
plot it on here is the upper level west
to east wind speed so I mentioned that
when the upper level winds weaken we
tend to get a wavier flow and this is
supporting that idea if we focus in on
the just the north atlantic here we see
an even stronger response with a very
large increase in these extreme events
so to wrap up here I'm just want to show
you a couple of particular extreme
events and show you what the jet stream
look like at the time that they occurred
so again here's that heat wave of March
2012 where we broke thousands of high
temperature records across the eastern
two-thirds of the country contrasted
with this past winter and you can see
that the patterns are almost exactly
opposite so now you guys know all about
jet streams so you can almost predict
what the jet stream will look like in
these two cases right so March 2012 here
we have what the jet stream looked like
a big southward dip over the western
half of the country big northward swing
or a ridge over the east letting that
warm air extend all the way up into the
into Canada and here's the case for this
past winter this this pattern was in
place from early December through most
of februari it was it's been called the
ridiculously resilient Ridge that's the
ridge that's over the western west coast
there because it hung around for so long
this is going to be the topic of
research for the next few years for sure
record snows in Alaska this is a image
showing you what the actual jet stream
looked look like at that time with
Alaska up here and here's California we
had this big southward dip over the
Pacific allowing the cold air from the
Arctic to penetrate southward and the
jet streams bringing a lot of moisture
in from the Pacific the perfect
ingredients for heavy snow but notice
the very very amplified pattern in the
jet stream that flooding in Spain I
mentioned here's what the jet stream
look like then this was in September
again a very very amplified flow to the
jet stream bringing a lot of moisture in
from from the Atlantic Ocean right into
Spain so just to wrap up this concept
here we know that the Arctic is warming
very fast this image is showing you how
that layer of the air I described how
much thicker it's gotten over the last
couple of decades the red colors
indicate that it's the thickness has
increased much more over the Arctic than
it has everywhere around to the south
that is leading to a weakening of the
west to east winds in the upper level
flow we can measure this and this we
believe is leading to a change in these
waves in the jet stream from what we
call a zonal flow which is when the
waves are smaller to the orange color
when they're much larger and those
larger waves shift eastward more slowly
as do the weather patterns they create
and this tends to cause these types of
very persistent patterns like we had
this winter where we had very persistent
cold over the eastern half of the
country and warmth in the west and all
kinds of other extremes are related to
these waves in the jet stream as well
but this isn't the only game in town
where we know that there's a lot of
other large scale patterns in the
atmosphere the questions are how is this
relatively new change in the climate
system which is this recent warming of
the Arctic only in the last 15 years or
so how is it going to interact with
things like El Nino and the Pacific
decadal oscillation and a variety of
other things that go on in the climate
system like that so there's a lot of
work to be done yet this is a new
hypothesis if you will and there's a lot
of people working on it including us but
I think it's been useful because the
public has really kind of glommed on to
this idea they're really interested in
whether people love to talk about
weather and their understanding now that
climate change is not going to be this
gradual warming that's only going to
affect their grandchildren it's
happening today we're seeing it in
increasing extreme weather events and
we're starting to understand the
connection between weather and climate
change so thanks and if I you have any
questions I'd be happy to try to answer
them
you